détails charlotte gainsbourg vous avez
une carrière bien remplie vous avez
tourné dans une soixantaine de films
produits cinq albums j'ai adoré votre
nouveau documentaire jane par charlotte
s'affranchir tout prix
j'ai pas envie de m'affranchir après
avoir réalisé ce documentaire sur votre
mère sur votre relation avec la mère est
ce que vous êtes devenu vous une
meilleure mère est ce que vous êtes en
paix avec certaines choses
je suis en paix avec le fait que ce
rapport que je critique
jeu
oui je fais semblant ne pas le critiquer
mais je le critique quand même au début
en disant pourquoi
pourquoi il ya cette pudeur entre nous
pourquoi tu es
pas la même avec
quand kate était vivante avec elle et
tu as pas leur âme le même rapport avec
lui pourquoi on est si timide l'une et
l'autre et cette réserve d'où elle vient
donc c'est un rapport que je critique
parce que j'ai envie ce côté
familier proches on a toutes les deux
une pudeur l'une en face de l'autre et
je sais pas d'où elle sort aujourd'hui
je trouve ça très touchant notre apport
en fait je trouve qu'il ya de la beauté
danse
dans cette ambiguïté dans ce oui ce
rapport compliqué mais mais je trouve ça
beau aussi les ciels bleus je me
souviens que mon père ait
trouvé qu'il y avait pas grand chose à
dire des ciels bleus que c'était plus
quand ses ombrages et c'est plus c'est
plus intéressant la dernière fois que
j'ai rencontré votre sort do doyon elle
me disait que j'ai été élevée par des
parents enfin donc j'étais en fait le
parent dans la maison parce que c'est un
peu la même chose pour vous pas du tout
j'avais des parents qui étaient qui
s'amusaient qui n'étaient pas des
enfants qui étaient vraiment des figures
très forte mais qui avaient leur vie à
eux de folie dans les années 70
beuvry
[Musique]
parisienne hyper mondaine je suis très
heureuse d'ailleurs qu'ils aient eu qui
nous est peut-être dénigrer mais que qui
se soit autant amusé parce que ça ça
reflète beaucoup d'innocence et de
d'amour en fait je sais que j'ai des
parents qui sont aimés je trouve ça
vachement important votre première photo
elle est ici sur la pochette du sublime
jeune histoire de melody nelson vous
êtes dans le ventre de votre mère jane
birkin pour sackey son bouton ne ferme
pas on voit pas et avait pas de
retouches à l'époque un don qu'elle sait
pas du tout retouché mais on voit
qu'elle a le dernier bouton qu'elle va
fermer vous êtes en quelque sorte la
gardienne de l'oeuvre de votre père non
on est quatre enfants ouais mais comment
vous gérez justement ce patrimoine si
important les rééditions pour que son
oeuvre est vivant on maîtrise pas grand
chose je trouve pas qu'on soit oui on
est gardien du temple tous les quatre on
essaie de faire au mieux depuis 30 ans
31 ans bientôt
sans qu'on ait eu vraiment le de mode
d'emploi où on est tombé dedans comme ça
sans
heureusement qu'il ya justement des
artistes qui sont inspirées par lui qui
a
les maisons de disques différentes qui
qui reprennent et qui ont des idées
c'est pas nous qui faisons ces
rééditions c'est pas voilà c'est nous
ont dit oui non mais c'est pas c'est pas
grave je fais un détour par l'actualité
charlotte gainsbourg avec ce qui se
passe en ukraine parce que vos grands
parents sont d'origine russe ukrainienne
votre père serge gainsbourg parlait
beaucoup de ses origines il en était
fier
j'imagine que ça me touche beaucoup ce
qui se passe oui parce que depuis
toujours je dis que j'ai des dés une des
ancêtres russes enfin mon père a
toujours dit qu'il était juive russe
donc pour moi il y avait que questions
la russie
aujourd'hui je comprends qu'on n'est pas
russe on est complètement ukrainien
parce que les villes dont ma tante me
parle aujourd'hui c'est des villes
d'ukraine
et je comprends que voilà c'est le sait
le
les ancêtres on partage avec énormément
d'ukrainiens immigrés juifs qui ont fui
donc ça ça me touche énormément ce
conflit aujourd'hui parce que c'est un
conflit intérieur aussi on est russe
aussi enfin il y a il ya les deux après
il ya un despote poutine qui qu'il faut
combattre donc
j'ai été très fier et très en fait très
concerné par
le
le rôle de l'europe et
on a vu une parole européenne et c'est
important charlotte gainsbourg j'ai bien
hâte de vous revoir parce que vous
travaillez sur un nouvel album mais oui
mais ça me prend toujours beaucoup de
temps donc je sais pas quand il sera
fini merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]